[Music]
yes we I've known for a long time
it's been really hard for me to keep
secret thank you
I've known for a few months yes she is
such an incredible mom and I got to
spend some time with Luca on set this
year and he's just such an incredible
kid and that's on her you know and she's
been talking about having another baby
for four years and I'm so excited that
she gets that we were talking about like
the gender-reveal party and like my
whole thing with gender right now I'm
like come on but like girl do you girl
intended in that moment like do whatever
you need to do I'm here to celebrate at
all yeah so we all you know are looking
for them one way or another
she's got it she's preggers oh I love
pregnancy so much I have the fever so
hard right now like hey I want to be
pregnant but be like I can't wait to
start having kids I'm so excited you
guys already wrapped season five we're
outside to play hide the bump one of our
favorite games yeah for sure yeah
totally I don't even think Darren knew
until after we wraps honestly I think
sorry Darren I think we were like the
lat he was like the last one I think
yeah a lot of people knew before he did
you know but like understandably she
wanted to ton wise it's perfect she's
gonna have a baby we don't start
shooting until next year perfect maybe
you don't have
do that thing where she has a very
conveniently placed handbag
[Music]
[Applause]